you know i grew up a liberal democrat
because after all i'm a jew from new
york i went to colombia okay i got all
the credentials of i voted for jimmy
carter which i have for which i'm still
atoning
so i i just wanna i always ask
people who knew me tell me one position
i have now that i didn't have when i was
a liberal democrat
and and there's silence
i haven't changed they've changed
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the host of the dennis prager radio show
the founder of prageru or i should say
the co-founder of prageru and my rabbi
even though he's not really a rabbi
dennis prager welcome back to the reuben
report old friend
there is only one
slight
cloud over our being together again
and that is we are no longer living in
the same city
the same time zone or the same coast
i just want everybody watching to know
i miss dave and i miss david
well
we
dave and david miss you and sue we miss
you a lot we're going to see in a couple
weeks but actually
actually that is the perfect place to
start this conversation because two days
before i officially left los angeles and
when i left you know it was a quick
thing and i was just out of there i
hosted a dinner at my house with a
couple couples just to say goodbye some
of the people who were the formative
people of my years in in los angeles and
you you and sue were there obviously
and we talked about whether it is right
or just or worthwhile to stay and fight
and when you should know it's time to go
i obviously felt it was time to go
um
you have a little you know you have
other obligations and things but why
don't we just start the conversation
there because yeah you're you're there
i'm here and yet we see the world in
such a similar way
um and we're living in different coasts
in very different planets right now
i am not
staying
this might help
give your viewers
more faith in how committed i am to
honesty
i am not staying for the noble reason of
fighting i fight every day
i would fight if i were in florida but i
wouldn't be fighting florida i would be
fighting wokism
leftism
wherever it is
i'm not staying because i think
california is salvageable
at this time i do not think it is
salvageable
people who vote for district attorneys
who will increase death
uh are not salvageable
so uh i'm here because there are too
many people i adore you
two were among them
and you left and i totally understand
why you did
but i founded a synagogue here which
means a great deal to me
every single week i have this
time with people i truly love
i speak at the synagogue i'm sort of the
again the unofficial rabbi
and of course other people i've been
here for 40 years it's a long time you
make a lot of friends
but i'm not here because of the fight
issue
if you want to fight you can fight
anywhere in this country from montana to
california to florida and i wish
everybody did fight
but specifically with regard to
california i'm here because of people by
the way if a lot of the conservatives of
california move
to other states that's great for the
battle against the left
because it increases
the
non-left vote in those states
the worry is when californians who are
on the left
flee california or flee new york
and then bring the policies that they
fled to the new states
that's sick
well i i can tell you from being here
just for a couple of weeks i've
mentioned this on the show almost every
day the people that i'm meeting here who
are the new refugees here they know what
they fled and why they fled so i'm very
happy that's right i'm very very hopeful
on that front but but all right what do
you think let's let's go with that for a
little bit what do you think really is
the future of america if
this mass migration happens if basically
there'll be sort of minorities
like you in california that that will be
fighting the good fight but won't have
political power and then we'll have
places in red states that may be more
aligned with us what what is the united
bond of the united states of america if
this continues in this direction which
to me it has to actually at this point
for all intents and purposes there are
two americas
i think americans are more divided now
than they were during the civil war
during the civil war they were divided
on this spectacularly important issue of
slavery
but otherwise they were not divided
and now that's a big deal obviously but
still right now
the division is
on every issue we agree
essentially on nothing important
and uh
look
there's a fantasy in me that all the big
cities of the country secede
it's not geographically possible because
you couldn't have in such a
non-contiguous country
but if new york and los angeles and
chicago
and san francisco and seattle and
philadelphia
if they all made their own country and
left the rest of us even with all the
finance that they would take all the
money all the banks
it would be paradisical
for the rest of us
but uh it's it can't happen because of
the geographical issue
so what has to happen is i think what
you just
painted the the scenario you painted was
of of people coalescing in the states
they agree with
and then what makes us united i mean
does that work i mean we're not united
we we're not i mean look i i hate saying
it i love this country
we're not united tell me an issue that
left and right agree on uh i think if
the rest of this podcast could be spent
waiting for you to give me an answer
yeah well there used to have been a
healthy tension let's say between
liberal and conservative or republican
and democrat something like that now it
just doesn't exist it's just basically
well it doesn't exist because because
they're
we're not fighting liberals we're
fighting leftists
if we were fighting liberals there would
be a united states of america
i mean if you were fighting liberals i'd
be on the other side of you
fine i'd be on the other side of me
i you know i grew up a liberal democrat
because after all i'm a jew from new
york who went to colombia okay i got all
the credentials of i voted for jimmy
carter which for which i'm still atoning
so i i just wanna i always ask
people who knew me tell me one position
i have now that i didn't have when i was
a liberal democrat
and and there's silence
i haven't changed they've changed would
there maybe be one like so when you were
a liberal democrat you were still
pro-life
and now we're talking oh that's a good
point yeah i i i have evolved on
abortion by the way not for religious
reasons
yeah but for science reasons
solely
you can't deny it's a human being at a
very early age i mean it's just
people who say follow the science are
generally lying if they followed the
science they would know that a human is
being killed certainly from the the the
heartbeat or or brain waves when they
begin
okay uh that we could argue about
zygotes there's an honorable argument on
both sides
but but not but not in the the end of
the first trimester if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell